[Musique]
au lendemain de la semaine sanglante les
conseils de guerre dont tiers a
multiplié le nombre fonctionne à perdre
haleine près de 4500 condamnés dont 23
femmes sont envoyées en nouvelle
calédonie pour y subir des peines de
travaux forcés de déportation en
enceinte fortifiée et de déportation
simple les premiers arrivés vont y
rester huit ans mais il n'y a presque
plus aucune trace de leur passage
en effet l'administration locale
soucieuse d' effacer tout ce qui
pourrait rappeler que la nouvelle
calédonie fut pendant plus de 50 ans
terre de bagnes au même titre que la
guyane à raser les bâtiments recouverts
les cimetières brûler les archives et
noyé dans une même volonté d'oubli
condamnés de droit commun et condamnés
politiques
heureusement la mémoire a la vie dure et
se moque des interdits parfois nous
parvient traversant le temps le souvenir
d'un déporté que ses descendants n'ont
pas oublié
c'est le cas de madame georgette chez
kelton 85 ans et de son fils max
respectivement petite fille et
arrière-petit-fils du déporté henri
etienne mangeons c'était a déporté
politique
je vais demander
il m'a dit ce que j'ai fait j'ai montré
avec mon endroit
l'ennemi il a été pris et il a été
envoyé aux en déportation
oui en calédonie pendant combien de
temps puisqu'il est allé en calédonie
est allé à
[Musique]
il n'a pas été à lille ou de paris
faisait pas voilà on va les déportés à
l'île des pins
c'était un grand fort d'ailleurs comment
il est et il était bien estimé en
calédonie c'est un bonhomme on est
connecté
certaines des principales qualités
qu'est ce qu'il faisait a nommé a
travaillé très fort et après il a pris
sa retraite sera il était cordonnier il
était beau thierry en premier quand ils
étaient jeunes ils étaient coordonnées
c'était le premier cordonnier nos
meilleurs monstre un très bon condamner
tout le grand monde de nouméa allait
fermer se mangeant le cordonnier est ce
que votre grand père vous parlait
parfois d'autres déportés qui étaient
avec lui soit à l'île des pins soit à à
ducos je pense par exemple à des gens
célèbres comme louise michel away louise
michel ont ils m'ont parlé sûrement
michel elle était laide en art et sa
photo c'est parce qu'elle est revenue
elle est élève la pauvreté grande meg
mais les led agent qui est rouvert à
envoyer elle avait sept chats je suis
plus combien de chiens elle vivait que
pour ses bêtes
le boucher l'écart des titres avion pour
les michel moi c'était une bonne forme
avait bon coeur un malheureux pour
revenir le monde est un morceau de pain
elle était prête à y donner une très
bonne forme
est ce que vous êtes fiers de votre
grand père oui monsieur se fier de mon
grand père et de ma mère et de mon fils
non loin de chez madame chez kelton
vigeant kako soixante dix huit ans ils
ne se connaissent pas tous les deux
pourtant lui aussi a gardé le souvenir
même s'il ne l'a pas rencontré de son
grand père jean théophile riche noble et
révolutionnaire
moi je n'ai pas connu mais mon père
disait qu'il est c'était un bel homme il
avait une belle tête il y ressembler au
président de la chambre des députés de
l'époque qui s'appelait paul deschanel
il dit il était bien c'est quand même un
itinéraire fantastique pour un homme il
aurait pu vivre riche mon père disait
justement quand tu là il aurait pu
surtout croyez même à ses débuts à paris
je le sud un autre cousin il a eu il a
eu des terrains au bois de boulogne
il a revendu pour prescrire et puis il a
préféré abandonner tout ça à le mordu de
la politique mais je crois que d'après
mme ampe et il est rentré dans la
commune un petit peu pas patriotti soyez
à cause de voiliers de comment cette
capitulation dans les abords de napoléon
iii
ensuite l'armée de de base elle qui
s'est rendue ce de l'armée française de
l'époque qui se rendaient rendu les les
prussiens avec comme aux tiers qui
s'étire à l'époque pierre à ceux qui
étaient là alors il ya eu beaucoup de
révo d'ouvriers d'intellectuels il
voulait quand même
et essayer de faire quelque chose vous
pensé que c'était des gens dangereux
qu'on l'aide
moi je crois pas il y en avait peut-être
il y en a peut-être vous pensé ces
ouvriers qui étaient tellement
malheureux qui faisait douze heures par
jour
on importe des antennes profiter de la
dent 1
ils ont peut-être profiter de cette
insurrection là c'est comme toujours
c'est qu'on voit la révolution de 1789
mais voyons 1780 il y avait tout de même
des tentes en des robespierre dégâts
bien moi je pense qu'il y avait il ya
des gens qui croyaient bien faire
pendant 73 jours après avoir refusé de
capituler devant les prussiens et de
livrer leur canot ou versailles et les
communards ont essayé malgré des erreurs
et des faux pas de jeter les bases d'une
nouvelle société sans classes où
régnerait la justice sociale tiers pour
qui force doit rester à la loi engage
immédiatement les combats
d'abord contenue à la périphérie les
versailles et se rapproche peu à peu de
la capitale à partir du 1er mai paris et
bombarder systématiquement et l'effort
de la ceinture doivent être
progressivement évacués le 21 mai les
troupes gouvernementales entre dans la
ville par la porte de saint cloud
pendant une semaine la semaine sanglante
les combattants de la commune lutte
quartier par quartier maison par maison
barricades par barricades mais la
commune qui a tant fait sur le plan des
mesures sociales n'a pas su organiser sa
défense
nili et son action à celle de la
province et de la paysannerie
elle est obligé de reculer
l'armée de versailles progresse et
fusils la résistance est à son comble
c'est un véritable massacre
les hommes les femmes les enfants
tombent par dizaines de milliers plus de
30000 alors que les troupes
gouvernementales n'ont pas perdu 900
hommes
depuis le début de l'insurrection
ceux qui ne sont pas fusillé sur le
champ sont arrêtés à versailles à satory
sur les pontons quarante mille
prisonniers sont entassés dans la tente
d'un jugement plus de cinquante mille
décisions de justice ont rendu 23
communards sont condamnés à mort et
exécutés
72 voix leur peine capitale commuée en
détention perpétuelle des milliers sont
condamnés à la déportation ou à la
transportation
ils vont passer plusieurs mois parqués
dans des conditions épouvantables dans
la tente de leur départ pour une prison
française pour la guyane où la nouvelle
calédonie
la nouvelle calédonie est devenue
colonie française en 1853 elle somnole
tout d'abord pendant dix ans sans
affectation particulière puis en 1864
paris décide d'en faire une terre de
colonie pénale c'est à dire un lieu où
les condamnés aux travaux forcés après
avoir purgé une partie de leurs peines
pourront être libérée à condition de
s'installer sur place de fonder une
famille et d'y développer une plantation
les premiers fort ça arrive et avec eux
des militaires des commerçants des
fonctionnaires de l'administration
pénitentiaire et civils en 1872 nouméa
compte environ 3500 habitants
sans oublier quelques 500 mélanésiens
qui servent de domestique et de
manoeuvre
civiliser les kanaks réhabiliter les
forces à produire le nickel dont la
grande aventure commence
voilà à quoi ressemble la nouvelle
calédonie où arrivent dès octobre 1872
les premiers déportés communards après
un voyage épouvantables dans des cages
de 100 personnes logées dans l'entrepont
de vieilles frégate désaffecté certains
nous en ont laissé témoignages notre
nourriture d'aujourd'hui se compose de
deux sardines et pas de soupe
les vers blancs et rouges envahissent le
biscuit tout le monde en trouve peu ou
prou l'eau devient de plus en plus
mauvaise celle d'aujourd'hui est plus
coloré que celle des mares à purin les
cages sont ouvertes successivement une
fois par jour pour une promenade d'une
demi-heure sur le pont plutôt pour une
station d'une demi heure
car l'espace qui nous est réservée est
si étroit qu'il est seulement possible
de piétiner sur place qu'on ajoute à un
tel régime
l'assaisonnement des violences et des
grossièretés que nous avons à subir de
la part des surveillants qui montent la
garde
revolver au point autour de nos cages et
l'on se fera une idée de ce que peut
être un tel voyage prolongé pendant cinq
à six mois en passant par les chaleurs
torrides de l'équateur
et l'effroi des mers australes
[Musique]
enfin le 3 octobre 1872 au bout de cent
cinquante trois jours de traversée nous
sommes en vue de la nouvelle calédonie
quel soupir de soulagement sort de
toutes les poitrines
quelle joie nous éprouvons devant la
terre de déportation il faut pour le
comprendre avoir souffert les cinq mois
de cycle infernal
je ne sais même pas si huit ans plus
tard lorsque l'ennemi steam rendit la
liberté j'ai joui d'un sentiment de
délivrance pareil au jour où je quittais
la danaé pour être prisonnier dans
l'enceinte fortifiée de l'après-ski
ducos
le voyage de la danaé fut
particulièrement éprouvant car le
commandant qui était convaincu que la
flotte de l'international allait venir
délivrer les communards redoubler de
sévérité
il y eu heureusement des voyages moins
tragique
par exemple celui de la virginie je
crois que la virginie a été un des
voyages les moins d et grave parce que
le commandant de bord est un ami de
rochefort un républicain pas socialiste
mais républicain hamid rochefort avant
le départ il a quand même invité toute
la famille de rochefort et rochefort lui
même à manger à sa table il était seul
et non pas dans une cage de 100
personnes au bout d'un certain temps il
a demandé que brocade déportés puisse
bénéficier du même régime mais il avait
un régime de faveur le commandant
s'occuper de sa nourriture également ce
commandant républicain je crois que
c'est le seul exemple de voyages qui
s'est très bien passé le commandant
républicain avait beaucoup d'admiration
pour louise michel et s'apercevant
qu'elle mourrait de froid qu'elle
sortait rêver sur le pont sans
chaussures et 100
bas de laine alors qu'il faisait
températures au dessous de zéro il s'est
ému il a cru qu'elle allait mourir
et sachant le caractère très ombrageux
de michel qui refusaient de pactiser
elle avec les autorités donc avec le
commandant de bord qui aurait refusé un
don du commandant de bord il allait
trouver rochefort mais en disant
rochefort vous qui êtes juste en face de
sa cellule de la cellule de louise
michel est ce que vous pouvez pas
essayer de lui donner des vêtements plus
chauds pour empêcher qu'elle ne meure je
vais vous les donner mais fait les
passer comme de vous et clandestinement
et rochefort a essayé de le faire louise
michel lui a renvoyé les les objets en
lui disant qu'il en avait besoin qu'elle
n'en avait pas besoin
rochefort a écrit à nouveau en disant
qu'ils étaient trop petits pour lui que
les que les bas de laine était trop
petit pour lui que vraiment il ne
pouvait pas les utiliser et elle a fini
par condescendre à accepter ça de
rochefort mais quelques jours après les
a donnés à une autre détenu donc tous
les stratagèmes du commandant qui avait
bon coeur disent on a fini par faire
long feu 2872 à 1878 20 convois de
déportés vont débarquer leurs
prisonniers en nouvelle calédonie le
plus long des voyages dur 190 jour le
plus court
88 cela dépend du temps et de
l'itinéraire par le cap horn ou par le
canal de suez qui vient d'être ouvert
lille nous qui était vraiment une île à
cette époque on a depuis construit cette
digue qui la rattache à la grande terre
avec les pierres des bâtiments du bagne
abrite plusieurs milliers de forçat
c'est là qu'on dirige les communards
condamné aux travaux forcés
ceux qui ont été jugés pour attaque à
main armée assassinat incendie
volontaire destructions d'immeubles ou
qui avaient été condamnées à mort et
dont la peine avait été commuée
nous sommes au milieu au coeur même de
l'univers concentrationnaire enfin du
bagne c'est à dire du pénitencier dépôt
il y as derrière nos une allée centrale
c'est ce qu'on a appelé vulgairement
d'ailleurs le boulevard du crime
c'était l'allée principale du bagne de
chaque côté à droite et à gauche il y
avait
une douzaine de bâtiments maçonné qui
étaient les grandes cellules où l'on
concentré les bannières pour la nuit
et au milieu de ces quatre à six mille
bagnard de droit commun donc dé
transporter de droit commun il y avait 3
123 déportés de la commune qui vivaient
là parmi eux et sans aucune
considération spéciale il était soumis
au même régime totalement c'est à dire
qu'ils avaient abandonné leurs noms n
étaient appelés que par un numéro il
était humiliation suprême tendu rasé
cela va de soi et surtout tendu et cela
c'était probablement l'humiliation la
plus forte au moins aussi forte que
celle des vêtements qui était pour le
moins sommaire
aux dires de ceux qui en sont revenus le
bagne c'était vraiment pire que la mort
a lille nous contrairement à ce qui
s'est passé précédemment à cayenne le
régime de la transportation s'applique
intégralement aux déportés politiques
les communards sont fondus dans la masse
des autres condamnés aucun si aucune
catégorie
aucun indice ne permet de les considérer
à part ils ne sont plus des politiques
mais simplement des droits communs
sur deux rangs à de [ __ ] vers aussi
faire un surveillant à double ballon
d'argent
selanne accueil plein de 12 promesses le
bourreau petit ces aides
les correcteurs dont un [ __ ] aux
proportions herculéenne une trentaine de
surveillants militaire plus grossier et
plus brutaux les uns que les autres nous
commande de vider nos sacs et nos poches
ceci fait les divers objets nous
appartenant sont foulées aux pieds jeter
au loin pendant qu'on nous tarabustent
violemment ont cogné à tort et à travers
on jette à la mer les lettres les
photographies les petits riens que les
malheureuses exilés ont gardé si
précieusement en souvenir de ceux qui
les ont aimés qui les aime au corps et
sont demeurés là bas tout au bout du
monde
les épithètes un femmes se croisent le
correcteur [ __ ] est à la sable il
frappe d'une main pendant que de l'autre
il s'empare de tout ce que ses yeux de
fauves des cours
enfin fatiguer nos bourreaux nous parque
sur une espèce de plateau sur lequel
quelques tentes sont dressées à notre
intention
lille nous est un second temps faire
doit être banni toute espérance
[Musique]
quand un homme arrive au bagne il perd
sa personnalité les raser habillé d'un
costume spécial enchaîné par le pied
désigné par un numéro astreint aux
travaux les plus durs il devient une
machine mais une machine qui sans et qui
souffre supplice plus atroces
il n'est pas seulement soumis à la règle
d'une loi inflexible il est assujetti
aux caprices d'une horde de tyrans qui
s'appelle le corps des surveillants
[Musique]
l'avis du fort ça se résume en deux mots
travailler souffrir
[Musique]
levée avec le jour il passe sa journée
sur les chantiers de l'état occupé sous
un soleil brûlant aux travaux les plus
pénibles
son salaire est nul aussi faible qu'il
ne lui suffit pas pour se procurer du
tabac son alimentation est ignoble est
insuffisante
la nuit ils couchent sur un lit de camp
avec dix neuf autres infortunés comme
les jamais un instant de solitude de
recueillement ou de répit le dimanche
est consacré au lavage et aux offices
catholiques obligatoire pour lui
quelle que soit sa confession il ne peut
écrire qu'une lettre par mois à sa
famille et ne reçoit qu'une réponse
l'une et l'autre sont ouvertes et ne
doivent traiter que des questions de
santé
en même temps qu'il est soumis à toutes
les fantaisies frivole qui peuvent
traverser la cervelle de son gardien à
ces outrages et à ses voies de fait le
forçat est passible de peines
administratives et réglementaires qui
sont la cellule et le fouet
[Musique]
la peine du fouet est appliquée deux
fois par semaine en présence du bagne
assemblée au son du tambour
le patient est attaché sur un banc
entièrement nue pour recevoir 10 15 20
coups de fouet
le plus l'instrument du supplice est une
forteresse de cuir manier avec une
habilité redoutable par un bourreau
spéciale à chaque coup la peau gonfle
comme par l'effet d'une brûlure au 4e ou
5e le sang jaillit la douleur est atroce
est l'homme le plus énergique a besoin
d'un effort presque surhumains pour ne
pas tourner 15 cours entraîne toujours
une incapacité de travail de plusieurs
semaines et il n'y a pas d'exemple d'un
condamné qui est puant supporter 40
cents expiré
[Musique]
en face du bagne de lille nous de
l'autre côté de la baie par ou pénètre
les bateaux qui viennent de france se
trouve la presqu'île du causse si la
queue sont installés les communards
condamné à la déportation en enceinte
fortifiée un rêve à côté du bail sur ces
collines arides ou ne proliféraient pas
encore les faux mimosas 918 déportés et
les épouses d'une centaine d'entre eux
autorisés à séjourner à la presqu'île
vivent isolés du reste du monde par un
cordon de troupes et la peur des requins
les déportés sont répartis en cinq ou
six camps formé de baraques en plancher
des 8 militaires hors de service où l'on
étouffe pendant l'été où l'on patauge
dans la boue pendant la saison des
pluies
[Musique]
chaque abri reçoit 12 hommes qui ont un
mac pour couchettes et pour ustensiles
commun une marmite et une cruche les
vivres sont distribuées chaque matin à
un guichet spécial et se compose
quotidiennement de 250 g de viandes
avariées ou de la rance 750 grammes de
pain ou biscuits 100 g de haricots secs
et 16 grammes de café l'administration
qui distribuent ces vivres crusnes
alloue aux déportés ni combustible ni
substance grasse il faut pourtant qu'il
arrive à les faire cuire s'il veut
manger mais cette difficulté est devenu
si épineuse qu'on le peut de bois qui se
trouvaient autour des camps étaient
épuisés qu'un grand nombre de proscrits
a pris l'habitude de consommer sa viande
ou son lard absolument cru
[Musique]
si on ajoute à ces vivre une
distribution annuelle de vêtements à
savoir un costume de toile un costume de
l'aisne de chemise et deux paires de ces
fameux souliers à semelle de cartons que
la guerre de soixante dix a rendu
célèbre on aura le tableau complet des
libéralités que l'administration
coloniale réserve aux déportés nous
sommes en plein coeur de la nouvelle
cité de thym du mais cela correspond
exactement à la cité de thym du de la
déportation de 1872 à 1880 la ont vécu
500 600 700 peut-être 800 communes à la
parenthèse savez vous combien il ya
d'habitants dans cette cité au dos lors
d'un millier à l'heure actuelle donc à
peu près autant qu'il y avait des portes
et à peu près autant
alors ici là au coeur de cette cité les
déportés vivait donc à la place de ces
immeubles à la pâte et ses immeubles
dans toutes les zones à peu près plâtre
c'est à dire où on a construit le plus
économiquement maintenant et alors
qu'est ce qui reste comme trace de cette
erreur plus rien puisque les campements
était fait de choses vraiment peu
durable il n'y avait pas de bâtiments en
dur
seuls les bâtiments administratifs mais
que nous verrons quand nous serons à
limbourg et est ont été en partie en dur
tous les autres c'était en chaume ou
c'étaient des petites tentes et par
conséquent tout va durer quelques années
c'est tout il n'ya aucun vestige le seul
ce sont les morts et les morts il est
mort 80 personnes qui sont qui ont été
enterrés dans un cimetière à côté lycée
en fait le cimetière n'existe plus c'est
route le recouvre un bulldozer de
l'administration l'a rasée en 1971 il y
avait 88 tomber un mausolée érigé en
mémoire d'une fille de déporté morte à
ducos à 16 ans
la petite emma piffaut alors afin que le
souvenir de ses morts et des centaines
de déportés qui souffrirent en ces lieux
pendant huit ans ne se perdent pas le
kiwanis club de nouméa a fait graver une
plaque avec les noms de ceux hommes
femmes enfants qui repose à jamais à
cinq mille lieues de paris
[Musique]
une dizaine de femmes ont été déportés
dans l'enceinte fortifiée de la
presqu'île du causse elle habite un
baraquement à s'éloigner du camp à
l'extrémité du territoire ce ne sont pas
comme on pourrait le supposer des
mégères ou seulement des aventurières et
des filles elles ne sortent pas d'une
catégorie inférieure à la moyenne des
déportés il y à une chemise hier et une
blanchisseuse mais deux personnalités
intéressantes domine le groupe
l'une déjà fatigués par la vie madame le
mail d'intelligence remarquable d'esprit
claire et s'agace elle compte parmi les
têtes du parti socialiste
l'autre est une institutrice louise
michel âgé d'environ 30 ans elle à la
bonté angélique l'inaltérable douceur la
patience inépuisable le dévouement
l'abnégation d'une sainte
sa charité est absolue sitôt qu'elle
reçoit un peu d'argent des siens elles
ne distribuent jusqu'au dernier sou à
des camarades je l' ai vus pendant des
mois confiné à sa case en jupon en
camisole en savate parce qu'elle avait
fait don de ses robes et de ses
chaussures
[Musique]
en tournant un peu sur le chemin de thym
du c'est la case de l'heureux où il joue
de la guitare elle a été fabriquée à la
presse qui lui même en bois de rose par
le père croisés dont la caser sur le
même chemin
plus loin la forge du père malézieux où
il nous fait avec des vieux bouts de fer
des serpes des outils de jardin une
foule de choses
la case de la cour tout au près puis
celle de provins l'un des tambours des
fédérés qui le plus furieusement bâti la
générale au jour où paris devait être
debout il y a encore la grande case de
kervizic du côté de l'hospice où
demeurent pas se doit et en attendant sa
femme celle de burlot tout seul en haut
du côté du père royer je les revois tout
l'énumération tiendrait un volume toutes
ces pauvres case de briques crues
couverte en paille des brousses qui vu
des auteurs avait l'air d'une grande
ville des temps antiques à 50 km au sud
de la grande terre
huit heures de navigation à l'époque de
la déportation par une mer magnifique
mais extrêmement dangereuse à cause des
récifs de corail se trouve l'île des
pins dans cet endroit paradisiaque à la
végétation luxuriante vécurent plus de
3000 communards condamné à la
déportation simple la plus légère des
peines ici aussi
presque toutes les traces de leur
passage ont disparu hormis ce cimetière
miraculeusement conservés nous sommes
au cimetière des communards de l'île des
pins
c'est à dire à l'endroit où 240 déportés
de la commune de paris
venant
il faut pour saint-antoine 2000 montant
de belleville et c'est vivent leurs
derniers sommeil et ce sont des hommes
jeunes je crois dans l'ensemble qui sont
morts ont d'une façon générale ces
déportés de communards de paris avait la
trentaine ou la quarantaine au maximum
c'était un homme jeune et ils ont marre
de quoi ils sont morts d'abord d'avoir
beaucoup souffert en france sur les
pontons
des ports où ils ont été détenus pendant
un an à peu près après la fin de la
commune et avant d'être embarqué vers la
nouvelle calédonie ils sont morts des
souffrances qu'ils ont supporté abords
des grands navires qui les a menés en
nouvelle calédonie et puis sont morts
également beaucoup de nostalgie il avait
la salle j de la france
beaucoup sont suicidés il était dans un
mauvais état intellectuel psychique
plutôt que physiques morales moral on ne
sait pas à qui appartient à telle ou
telle tombe à part deux exceptions oui à
part deux exceptions la colonne tronquée
de dormoy je ne sais pas d'ailleurs si
ce dormoy à une parenté avec le ministre
dormoy qui a été assassiné
du temps du mystère salengro et puis de
verteuil le gène de verteuil dont la
famille d'ailleurs a fait souche en
nouvelle calédonie d autres sont tout à
fait anonyme
ils ont non seulement anonyme mais comme
vous le remarquez ils sont cent croient
car les déportés de la communauté des
anticléricaux virulent et ils exigeaient
d'être enterrée et de ne pas avoir de
croix sur leurs tombes
il y a encore à nouméa aujourd'hui des
descendantes deux gènes de verteuil très
exactement des petites filles et une
arrière petite fille de sa soeur marie
venue le rejoindre en calédonie
lorsqu'il y avait été envoyé en
déportation
elles n'ont évidemment pas connu leurs
ancêtres enterrés à l'île des pins mais
parfois leur grand mère qui les a élevés
leur parler du passé je me rappelle un
soir regardez sa maison et qu'elle
disait tu vois ma fille j'ai vu des
manceaux de cadavres pendant la commune
aussi gros que cette maison tu vas
étaient tous des cadavres c'était et
français c'était des cadavres d'hommes
qui avaient été tués par les versaillais
probable m est-ce qu'elle parlait un peu
de gêne
l'angoissé trop c'était pas possible
toute son enfance le siège de paris
le la la commune le jugement le départ
de france ça l'aveyron ou ac pendant si
longtemps que vraiment ça lui faisait
monter les larmes elle ne pouvait pas
est ce qu'elle est elle aussi un peu un
peu comme une harde elle était restée
quand même vos minables
moi je crois dans son
quand elle racontait des choses à ses
petits enfants et même à ses
arrière-petits-enfants parce que moi
j'ai en j'en ai entendu parler par mon
mari qui l'a bien connu
elle aimait bien par exemple quand un de
ses arrière petits fils lui disais qu'en
mer
je suis communiste elle me disait tu
auras je sais pas si c'était un sou
dessous trois sous à l'époque mon baby
est dissous et il savait qu'il pourrait
avoir un sorbet ou des bonbons avec ça
et alors il avait remarqué que ça
marchait très bien et elle aimait bien
entendre ce mot là et il ya une autre
anecdote aussi je pense qu'on pourrait
raconter ses
une fois dans la rade de nouméa un
bateau allemand a mouillé en rade et
s'adressa à mon mari elle lui disait tu
vois mon garçon si j'avais 20 ans si
j'avais 20 ans j'irai je plongerai je
mettrai une bande-son ce bateau est pour
elle le simple mot allemand ça
représentait tellement de choses que
elle se sentait presque capable de faire
une chose pareille d'aller faire sauter
un bateau ça l avait pas obligé la cause
profonde la rue des causes profondes de
la commune moi mon avait exactement
l'origine c'était la revanche il ne
pouvait pas encaisser le la notion de
défaite le siège de paris toutes ces
misères qui vous laisse écouter
l'occupant hors de france
qu'est ce que les résistants très entre
39 44
c'est avec le même idéal qui sont partis
selon les ja décor est madame collecte
même si il y avait une commune de paris
demain vous feriez la même chose que vos
ancêtres je sais pas si j'aurai leur
courage je ne sais pas si j'aurai leur
courage qu'ils qu'ils ont fait si vous
voulez le leur philosophie me plaît
assez 1
mais je ne sais pas si j'aurai leur
courage je pense qu'on est bien moins
bien trempé qui n'était je vais demander
à votre tante alors à madame joly s'il y
avait une commune de paris madame et si
vous aviez peut-être quelques années
deux mois que feriez vous comme votre
soeur comme votre grand verre vraiment
mer plutôt comme balle en main moi j'ai
un caractère plutôt souny jeu j'admire
ceux qui font de belles choses mais je
crois que j'en suis incapable je ne
trouve la paix la tranquillité
je trouve qu'on a assez de malheurs qui
vous viennent directement
moi j'ai toujours conseiller mes enfants
dans tout ce qui a pu se passer ici de
rester tranquille de rester local
cela dit vous êtes quand même vous êtes
vous n'avez pas honte de vos ancêtres
ont pas du tout vous êtes fier d'eux
fier de ma grand mère surtout parce que
c'était lui qui a tout payé cette
branche de bourgines ok t'es la forme et
qui nous a élevés nous bien vraiment
elle a eu de bons résultats pour
aujourd'hui j'ai un jour ninja peine
fiat est oui d'abord parce que c'est
hors du commun et que probablement cela
a forgé mon caractère
notre vie donc j'en ai une certaine
fierté
mais je déplore c'est que jal aurait
amené autant de misère et minimiser
avions durer des années des dizaines
d'années c'est hérite et il faut
longtemps longtemps pour effacer
le gène de verteuil fait partie du
premier convoi qui touchent le sol de
l'île des pins en cet automne 1872 par
le débarcadère de la presqu'île de
couteau ce n'est pas une île déserte
bien au contraire
700 cougnet motoc tone y vivent depuis
des siècles ils viennent d'être
évangélisée lorsque l'administration
française décide d'y implanter pour
faire cesser une guerre de religion près
de mille habitants catholique de l'île
de maré qui s'opposent à leurs frères
protestants
ce surcroît de population crée une
situation alimentaire extrêmement
délicate que vient aggraver l'annnonce
de la prochaine arrivée de milliers de
déportés
sur place l'émotion est intense le
gouverneur de la riche prix négocié un
accord avec la souveraine de lille la
reine hortense et son mari le grand chef
samuel les deux tiers de l'île
à l'est la partie la plus fertile seront
réservés à la population kunje et omar
est un qui n'ont pas été renvoyés à
l'île de lifou 4000 hectares situé dans
la partie ouest de l'île
la moins fertiles seront affectés à la
déportation
c'est la partition mais par ailleurs
rien n'est prêt pour accueillir les
premiers déportés qui débarque le 4
octobre 1872 sur le sable neigeux
éblouissant de couteau pendant quelques
jours ce ne furent que course échevelée
à travers les bois excursions folle dans
la brousse nuit à la belle étoile avec
une maigre aux couvertures pour abris
nous savourions à pleins poumons la
liberté relative qui nous étaient
laissés sans plus songer au lendemain
qui cependant ne ménageait d'amères
déceptions tout entier au bonheur de
fouler la sauvage prairies de contempler
cette nature tropicale dans ces
manifestations capricieuse et étrange
le gouverneur authier de la riche ries
avait trompé son gouvernement lorsqu'il
l'a visait que tout était prêt pour nous
recevoir nous trouvâmes la solitude
rien de plus quelques misérables ut
construite à la hâte par un détachement
de forces à offrir à une centaine
d'entre nous un méchant abri contre le
soleil des plus dangereux à cette époque
de l'année
bien souvent l'impossibilité de faire
cuire nos aliments étaient telles que la
lassitude s'emparait de nous ces jours
là nous nous jetions sournois mac humide
mal abritée par notre pauvre toiture de
chaume nous contentant de notre pain sec
et rêvant tristement à la patrie au
cheikh affection que nous avions laissé
à six mille lieues de nous
dès le 9 novembre 1872 un arrêté quelque
peu ironique du gouverneur divise l'île
des pins en cinq communes dans chacune
d'elles neuf conseillers municipaux sont
élus au suffrage universel
parmi eux le gouverneur choisi de droit
un délégué et deux adjoints qui forment
une sorte de conseil municipal la
cinquième commune tout au nord la plus
déshéritée et réservée aux arabes
victimes de la répression de la révolte
kabyle de 1871
comme les quatre autres communes elle
est placée sous la garde d'une brigade
de surveillance composé de chefs blancs
et deux gars de kanaks
la première commune celle du rau et le
centre le plus important de la
déportation ballière l'a surnommé des
portos police c'est là que réside aussi
les familles de déportés et les femmes
déportées les conditions de vie
notamment au début sont particulièrement
difficiles mais la liberté est
relativement grande puisque pendant dix
mois
les communards is chaque matin le
drapeau rouge
jusqu'au jour où l'administration s'en
émeut progressivement les conditions de
vie s'améliorent les hommes s'organisent
et comme la majorité des déportés et
former d'ouvriers manuel des bâtiments
commence à sortir de terre
hôpital fermes pilotes atelier église il
en reste quelques ruines de ci de là
perdu au milieu des faux mimosas qui
recouvre maintenant toute l'île
[Musique]
le bâtiment le mieux conservé et qui est
encore en fonction aujourd'hui même si
l'on est en train d'en changer les
canalisations
c'est le château d'eau
des dizaines de déportés de tous les
corps de métiers participent à sa
construction qui prend près de deux ans
avec la mise en place des différents
canaux d'alimentation en eau est ce cet
ouvrage était très important parce qu'il
avait monté également une scierie
hydraulique qui débitait les bois que
l'on prenait dans le nord de l'île les
bois qui haïti qui ont été travaillés
par la coopérative forestière pendant
longtemps ici et ce sont les déportés
alors qu'ils ont conscience celle des
portes et qu'ils l'ont ils l'ont
construit sur le plan d'un du capitaine
kayes et des dit on d'un spécialiste du
génie rural d'un déporté lui même s'ils
s'appelaient vie ronces et lorsque les
déportés travailler pour cet ouvrage
notamment
est-ce qu'ils étaient payés attentes y
travailler j'étais payé quand ils ne
travaillaient pas ils n'étaient pas
payés j'avais le droit au logement il
avait droit à la nourriture il avait le
droit ou vêtements mais ils n'étaient
pas payés mais il vous étaient tous
volontaires pour travailler parce qu'ils
s'ennuyaient trop et justement il avait
trouvé dans le capitaine kai un
incitateur absolument remarquable qui a
permis de faire ici de cette adduction
d'eau qui a permis de faire 139 km de
routes qui a permis de construire sans
deux bâtiments etc
c'était un type formidable
[Musique]
à cette époque considéré par les
historiens comme libéral
l'administration autorise près de 300
condamnés à subir leur peine de
déportation simple à nouméa à condition
qu'il y ait des moyens d'existence
parmi eux il y a le docteur rastoul
l'ancien chef du service de santé de la
commune qui devient vite le premier
médecin de nouméa achille balles hier
l'ancien chef d'état major d'euros
celles qui travaillent comme architecte
francis jourde l'ancien délégué aux
finances de la commune qui travaille
comme comptable
tous les deux vont d'ailleurs profiter
de leur liberté pour monter dans des
conditions restées encore aujourd'hui
mystérieuse leur évasion et celle de
pascal brou c'est l'ancien délégué aux
relations extérieures de la commune de
henri rochefort le célèbre polémiste
ancien ministre ancien député et de deux
autres déportés olivier pain et bastien
grant hill l'évasion proprement dite
elle s'est passé assez simplement il a
attendu le jeudi soir et le jeudi soir
tout était monté
ils se sont mis en caleçon de bain pour
ne pas donner les veilles et en caleçon
nager une certaine distance jusqu'à un
îlot l'îlot kaori prête ducos un petit
îlot nous nous étions tous trois plus ou
moins déchiré au point des falaises
olivier pain notamment portait aux
jambes d'assez fortes blessure dont il
s'aperçut plus tard pour l'instant nous
étions debout sur le pic volcanique
épluchant l'obscurité
analysant chaque bruits de vagues que
nous prenions pour un bruit de ram après
30 minutes d'une attente de plus en plus
désespérée une des lumières qui brillait
à lille nous disparu comme éclipsé par
un corps opaque
cuisez-les reparu et bientôt après le
réseau nas ou les claques de deux
avirons
c'est la barque ne puis m'empêcher de
crier imprudemment car ce pouvait être
un canot de ronde mais c'était le canot
de la délivrance
c'est en effet la barque dans laquelle
se trouve jour des balles hier les
quatre évadés monte à son bord met les
affaires sèche qu'on leur a apporté ils
rejoignent dans le port de nouméa un
bateau australien qui est à l'anc au
petit jour le pce appareils pour
l'australie les évasions sont
impossibles avait déclaré l'amiral
cesser les condamnés seraient mangés
d'un côté par les requins et de l'autre
par les naturelles en fait quelques
jours plus tard les communards débarque
à newcastle au nord de sydney l évasion
une rochefort a été dramatique pour les
autres déportés parce que
l'administration s'est ému c'était le
plus célèbre de la commune l'homme le
plus célèbre de la commune ancien chef
du gouvernement si un ministre ancien
député qui s'évader et c'est vraiment
sur l'évasion broche à cause de
l'évasion de rochefort qu' il ya eu un
changement dans la politique pratiquée à
l'égard des déportés on a passé de la
douceur à la fermeté et à la dureté à ce
que après un règne d'arbitraire je crois
que ça résume bien la chose
la répression est immédiate le
gouverneur le directeur de la
transportation et quelques autres sont
renvoyés en france
les 300 déportés libre qui résidait à
nouméa sont contraints de regagner l'île
des pins sur le champ il y retrouve des
garnisons renforcée qui ont reçu des
consignes très strictes et s'appuie sur
une gare de canac que l'on a monté
contre les déportés
plus que jamais la liberté apparaît
comme un rêve impossible aux déportés
accablé
[Musique]
c'est le début de ce que les historiens
appellent la déportation rigoureuse les
correspondances sont censurés les
déportés non plus la libre disposition
de leur argent afin de contrôler leurs
dépenses
en outre ils doivent se présenter à
l'appel chaque jour et non plus chaque
semaine
il est même biquotidien pour des
suspects comme le docteur rastoul qui a
dû abandonner sa femme et sa fille à
nouméa où eugène moureaux l'ancien
secrétaire de rochefort malgré la
sévérité de ces mesures
tous ne se laisse pas aller au désespoir
au contraire ils ne pensent qu'à
s'évader après l'évasion si heureusement
réussi de rochefort une véritable fièvre
d'escampette avait travaillé des
déportés il ne rêvait plus que barque
les transportant sur la côte
australienne
comme la plupart étaient d'excellents
ouvriers ils se mirent en mesure de
réaliser ce sont chaque nuit la forêt
longeant la mer fut remplie d'hommes qui
furtivement coupet et façonner des
arbres puis au petit jour les cacher
sous quelques amas de feuillages combien
furent surpris par les rondes de
surveillants et condamnés à des années
de prison pour vol du bois appartenant à
l'état et dont il était témoin dangereux
de faire des chutes
[Musique]
ce sont de véritables supplice que
subissent ceux des déportés simple qui
veulent conserver leur dignité
ils sont jetés sous un hangar pris par
les pieds entre deux bancs de bois que
vous avez pu voir figurer parmi les
instruments de supplice de la sainte
inquisition
il reste des mois entiers dans la même
posture sur la terre humide
quelquefois par un raffinement de
cruauté les pieds dans la barre de
justice
couché à plat ventre et les mains
attachées derrière le dos la prison la
cellule le supplice des bois de justice
ou l'enfermant rien n'arrête les
candidats à l'évasion
même s'il échoue de toutes ces
tentatives la plus célèbre et la plus
malheureuse fut sans conteste celle du
docteur rastoul par une nuit tempête
il quitte à l'île des pins avec dix neuf
camarades à bord d'une chaloupe qu'ils
avaient eux-mêmes construite sans doute
compte et ils trouvèrent à peu de
distance au large
un bâtiment qui les prendraient à son
bord car à ceux mis dans la confidence
qui leur disaient attendait au moins 24
heures partir par ce temps c'est aller à
la mort il répondait invariablement il
faut que nous partions cette nuit il a
l'air et personne ne plus jamais de
leurs nouvelles
quelques semaines plus tard probablement
afin de calmer les ardeurs d'évasion
l'autorité pénitentiaire exposé à la
presqu'île couteau des débris de bateaux
en affirmant que c'était tout ce qui
restait de la chaloupe du docteur
rastoul et de ses compagnons les
malheureux fugitifs n'avaient
pratiquement aucune chance de réussir
en effet l'île des pins est éloigné de
40000 de la grande terre et la mer
parsemée de recife de au fond est très
dangereuse par gros temps
en outre
des phénomènes de mascaret de ressac et
des courants violents rendent la
traversée de nuit quasi impossible mais
le désespoir du docteur rastoul était si
grand qu'il voulut quand même temps
telle aventure
[Musique]
après cette évasion manquer et les
nouvelles mesures de répression qu'elle
entraîna les déportés touche vraiment le
fond du désespoir
le plus triste c'est et l'ivrognerie à
quoi bon cacher la vérité bon nombre qui
en avaient l'occasion noyer leur
nostalgie dans le vin et calvin panne
était nécessaire d'en boire beaucoup
pour déraisonnée ou rendre tripes et
boyaux le samedi soir après la paye
faite aux déportés employés aux travaux
du génie
la route était jonché d'hommes ivre mort
qui n'avait peut-être pas bu deux verres
de ce liquide abominable la presqu'île
du causse n'échappe pas à
l'intensification de la répression
les déportés en enceinte fortifiée sont
soumis à deux appels journaliers à le
matin et un à la tombée de la nuit
le couvre-feu est instauré et il est
interdit de sortir des cases
après six heures du soir après l'évasion
de rochefort messieurs allez rond et
ribourg envoyé pour terrifier la
déportation probablement afin d'y faire
revenir aux forts et sûrs le ridicule
d'envoyer pendant un certain temps sur
les hauteurs autour de nant beau leaf
actionnaires qui avaient l'air de jouer
la tour de nesle avec décors grandioses
on entendait à intervalles réguliers au
sommet des montagnes sentinelle garde à
vous et par les nuits claires les
silhouettes noires d'effets actionnaires
se dessinait sur les cimes dans le clair
de lune intense
quelques-uns de ses fonctionnaires
avaient de belles voix c'était charmant
on sortait sur les portes des classes
pour les entendre et les voir puis les
voies sans roues r on était blasé sur
les silhouettes cela devint moins
attrayant mais c'était toujours jolie
après les choses ridicules il eu des
choses odieuses
les déportés furent privés de pain un
malheureux admis insensé par l'effroi
des choses vues fut visé comme on aurait
fait d'un lapin parce qu'il rentrait un
peu après l'heure dans sa concession
une autre fois se produisit un incident
plus grave un déporté chargé de bois
revenait de la forêt dont l'accès est
interdit depuis peu lorsqu'un garde
chiourme du nom de barrières
l'apostropha vous êtes allait couper du
bois sans permission
jetez votre charge à terre pour ça non
j'ai eu trop de peine à la coupe est à
la portée jusqu'ici vous refuser d'obéir
l'homme ne répond pas et continue son
chemin alors sans nulle autre
provocation barrière prend son revolver
larmes fait feu sur le déporter et lui
casse le bras
ce fut une action si méchante si large
qu'elle excita partout le camp un
mouvement d'indignation
ce n'est pas tout les femmes déportées
qui habitait jusque là baie de nabot
reçoivent l'ordre de la direction de la
déportation d'aller s'installer b de
l'ouest dans un grand baraquements
nathalie lemel et louise-michel refusent
elles réclament le droit de vivre comme
elles l'entendent
avec qui elles veulent dans de petites
cases séparer ainsi que le prévoit la
loi
elle obtient satisfaction et finissent
par s'installer dans ce qui va
dorénavant s'appeler la bd dame
[Musique]
aubagne de lille nous la répression est
pire que partout ailleurs
l'impunité est totale et les syndicats
de l'administration pénitentiaire s'en
donnent à coeur joie des actes de
brutalité s'était auparavant commis mais
il était d'isoler le fait de quelques
alcoolique auquel une administration
sans contrôle livrer la vie de gens qui
pour n'être que de vulgaires condamné n
était pas moins des êtres humains
et en cette qualité avait droit à sa
protection mais sous pris ce but her
l'exception de 20 la règle les
poussettes la crapaudine le revolver la
bastonnade et la guillotine se mirent à
danser une sarabande endiablée
dans les divers détachement on signale
une recrudescence des assassinats de
condamner d'hommes mise à la torture et
l'administration n'intervient que pour
féliciter les bourreaux
dans cette situation d'exception que
connaît la colonie où l'administration
pénitentiaire fait la loi et toute la
loi
les scandales de comptabilité publique
ne sont pas rares s'y ajoutent en ces
années d'horreur le naufrage de la
banque calédonienne de nouméa
nouvellement créé une famine sans suivi
un jour qu'un surveillant faisait
l'inspection des chantiers sa chienne
une espagnole superbe eu la fâcheuse
idée de se porter du côté de la carrière
à peine y est elle arrivée qu'un coup de
massue la battait et que 20 couteau la
dépecer moins de cinq minutes après il
n'en restait plus trace son maître
siffla à plat mirza hélas mira s'était
volatilisée dans la prison de l'hôpital
des durs du bagne qui a miraculeusement
échappé à la destruction ordonnée par le
conseil général en 1939 traîne encore
l'ombre de gustave maroteaux
journalistes il avait écrit dans son
journal la montagne
devant le refus dé versailles et
d'échangé blanqui contre l'archevêque de
paris
un fond dans la montagne j'ai fait le
serment de rousseau et de marat mourir
s'il le faut mais dire la vérité et ne
me parlez pas de dieu
le croquemitaine ne nous effraie plus il
y a trop longtemps qu'il n'est plus que
prétexte à pillages et assassinats
c'est au nom de dieu que guillaume abus
à plein casque le plus pur de notre sens
ce sont les soldats du pape qui
bombardent les ternes numbi fonds dieu
les chiens ne vont plus se contenter de
regarder les évêques il les mordront
nobel ne sapent la tirons pas sur les
scapulaire pas une voix ne s'élèvera
pour nous maudire le jour où l'on
fusillera l'archevêque d'arbois
[Musique]
pour ces lignes il fut condamné à mort
mais sa peine fut commuée en travaux
forcés à perpétuité
il est mort à 25 ans dans une cellule de
cette prison
[Musique]
oh
où
oui
[Musique]
ma cellule est un antre où je ne vis pas
seul ma compagne fantômes aux doigts
crochus l'habite la nuit l'aube le jour
elle dit ça linceul est sur moi ou la
noyer dans son orbite sa silhouette
grimacer flotte en dessinant sa
malédiction sur les grises muraille son
squelette parfois mettre un en ricanant
et ses avis de croo me mordent les
entrailles elle montre à ma fièvre un
mirage de pain qui s'efface toujours
salut hideuse fin
[Musique]
en france la situation politique évolue
on parle de plus en plus d' amnistie
alors les déportés de calédonie sentant
l'heure du retour proche s'organise et
la vie s'améliore mais en 1878 éclater
une très grave insurrection kanak
effectivement la direction de 8,78 est
un événement important dans l'histoire
de louise caioni puisqu'elle constitue
la plus grande
aussi bien dans le temps dans l'espace
que dans le temps que au nombre de
victimes des insurrections qui ont pu
avoir lieu au cours de l'histoire
calédonienne
elle est principalement situés dans les
régions de la fois bourail poule ou
paris c'est à dire des régions où
l'administration pénitentiaire avait
installé des centres pénitenciers et
avait permis à des forçats de d'avoir
des concessions pour s'installer donc
pour cultiver pour élever du bétail et
c'est vrai que ces concessions ayant
pris des terres sur les terres
précédemment occupé par des mélanésiens
il en était résulté une source de
conflit d'où est partie l'insurrection
qui a donc duré plusieurs mois dans
cette région et qui a fait beaucoup de
victimes à la bd dame louise-michel
comprend le sens du combat que mènent
les kanaks et affirme je suis avec eux
comme j'étais avec le peuple de paris
révolté écrasé vaincu elle raconte dans
ses mémoires les kanak ne purent
supporter les vexations qu'on leur
faisait endurer et ils engagèrent une
révolte qui comprenait plusieurs tribus
les colons ce que protégé
l'administration 100 ans avait enlevé
une femme kanak leurs bestiaux à les
pâtures et jusque sur la porte des cases
on leur distribue des terres ensemencées
par les tribus la plus grave de ces
tribus celle du grand chef a taillé
entraîna les autres on envoyait les
femmes portaient des patates des tarots
des ignames dans les cavernes lapierre
de guerre fut déterré et le soulèvement
comment ça du côté des kanaks avec des
fronts
des sagaies des casse têtes du côté des
blancs avec des obusiers de montagne des
fusils toutes les armes d'europe
dans leur majorité les communards
prennent parti contre les kanaks
ils forment même des corps francs pour
combattre aux côtés des troupes
régulières
une seule exception la bonne louise
michel
parmi les déportés les uns prenait parti
pour les kanaks les autres contre pour
ma part j'étais absolument pour eux par
une nuit de tempête
j'entendis frapper à la porte de mon
compartiment de la case qui est la
demande est ta yo répondu ton ta yo
signifie ami je reconnu la voix de nos
kanak à porter des vivres c'était en
effet il venait me dire adieu avant de
s'en aller à la nage par la tempête
rejoindre les leurs pour battre méchants
blancs disait-il alors cette écharpe
rouge de la commune que j'avais conservé
à travers mille difficultés je la
partageais en deux hélas leur donnait en
souvenir
l'insurrection kanak fut noyé dans le
sang
les tribus rebelles des six mais elles
sont en train de s'éteindre sans que la
colonie en soit plus prospère
le crâne bataille le chef rebelle est
présenté à l'exposition universelle de
paris tandis que le mouvement pour
l'amnistié s'amplifie grâce aux efforts
de victor hugo de clemenceau et de
gambetta
en calédonie les déportés reste encore
au retour vient en sauveur léger navire
hisser le captif à son bord ici dans les
faire il expire le bagne pire que la
mort en au coeur survie l'espérance et
si nous revoyons la france ce sera pour
combattre encore dès janvier 1879
mcmahon avant de se retirer signa décret
accordant 2245 grâces individuelles
les exilés d'europe et les premiers
déportés de nouvelle calédonie
reviennent en france après sept ans
d'absence
louise michel qui a bénéficié de ce
train de grâce refuse de quitter le
territoire de la déportation tant que
l'amnistié ne sera pas général elle
s'installe à nouméa où elle donne des
cours de piano et de dessins elle
consacre aussi une partie de son temps à
l'enseignement des kanaks
alors qu'elle vient d'être titularisé
comme maîtresse d école de nouméa et que
le président républicain jules grévy est
maintenant aux affaires l'aministie
total est enfin votée le 11 juillet 1881
pour le plus grand nombre
l'heure du retour a sonné seuls restent
dans la colonie les 393 morts enfouis
dans le sol calédonien et quelques
dizaines de déportés qui décide de
s'installer à nouméa avec leurs familles
louise michel quitte la colonie en
pleurant je reviendrai crie-t-elle à ses
amis en fait elle ne reverra jamais la
calédonie
à son arrivée à la gare saint lazare les
parisiens lui font un triomphe
[Musique]
et
e